Democrats in Washington are demanding
answers to their claim that President
Trump interfered in the case of Roger
stone the president's longtime friend
and Ally they say Attorney General
William bar will be asked at a House
Committee hearing next month if he was
pressured to overrule a prosecution
request to give Roger stone a long
prison sentence stone was convicted in
the investigation of Russian election
meddling been Tracy's at the White House
for us been the President did publicly
comment on this sentencing
recommendation so what's he saying now
about the claim that he interfered well
the president is congratulating Attorney
General bar for getting involved in
pushing for this lighter sentenced in
the nine years that prosecutors
originally recommended of course this
raises all sorts of questions about
whether or not the Justice Department is
acting on its own or if it's simply
doing favors for the president they
treated Roger stone very badly they
treated everybody very badly in the Oval
Office the president continued to lash
out at Roger stones prosecutors it's a
disgrace and frankly they ought to
apologize to a lot of the people whose
lives they've ruined in November a jury
found stone guilty of seven counts of
witness tampering lying to Congress and
obstruction the president's comments and
his attack on the judge overseeing the
case drew rare rebuke from Republicans I
think this is a situation where the
tweet was very problematic then I don't
think the president should have tweeted
about an ongoing case but they also said
they're not concerned about the
Department of Justice being independent
I have a lot of confidence that they got
it right here
the president praised Attorney General
William bar for intervening in the case
but Barra claims he did not coordinate
with the White House when he overruled
the prosecutors and sought a lighter
sentence Attorney General William bar a
lot of media
and the embarrassed bars actions have
prompted a flood of criticism from
Democrats and former Justice Department
leaders for the department to have cast
its lot firmly in this way is abysmal
Barr has repeatedly been accused of
working too closely with the president
including when he characterized the
findings of the Muller report before it
had been released I'm gonna make the
decisions based on the law and the facts
bar dismissed the criticism in an
interview with CBS News in May I think
it just goes with the territory of being
Attorney General in a hyper partisan
period of time it's now up to the judge
to decide how much prison time Roger
stone actually serves President Trump of
course could pardon him when asked
whether or not he plans to do that the
president said I don't want to say that
yet Gail all right thank you very much
Ben